♪ ♪
C'est la maison de rêve de
Sylvia Dekyndt, en plein coe
des Laurentides.
- On a acheté la maison pour
pour pouvoir se ressourcer.
- La vue bucolique du lac a su
charmer la nouvelle résidente
de Val-Morin.
en nature, c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est installé ici.
sont réveillés mardi matin dans
un bien mauvais rêve, au bord
du Lac Dream.
- On se lève le matin et on se c
a baissé assez rapidement.
- L'étendu d'eau s'est
pratiquement vidée en une nuit,é
a prodécédé au retrait de
poutrelles sur le barrage,
servant à contrôler le niveau
du lac. Un assèchement qui a
pris des riverains par suprise.
PIERRE MORIN
riverain, Lac Dream
- Je trouve ca désolant,
je trouve ça triste de voir ca,
c'est...
c'est même c'est même fachant.
SYLVIA DEKYNDT
riveraine, Lac Dream
- Pour moi c'est innaceptable.
Je ne peux pas comprendrequ'on t
un écosysteme pour enlever
des poutrelles.
- Le barrage doit absolument
être ouvert avant la saison
froide, répond la municipali
ce qui entraine le vidage du Lac
Dream. Les ingénieurs craignent
que l'ouvrage ne résiste pas à
une crue soudaine en plein hiver
ou au printemps puisqu'il est
impossible pour eurir
lors de ces saisons.
MÉLANIE LAPIERRE, Directrice des
travaux publics, Val-Morin
- C'est vraiment un enjeux de
sécurité pour les employés parce
que c'est des poutrelles de bois
orgent d'eorgent d'eorgent d'eoe
et c'est plus enlevable
de là l'hiver.
- Le barrage est pourtant neuf.
Il a été reconstruit après des
ons historiques en 2016
qui ont fait céder l'ancien.
Coût du projet : plus
de 400 000 $. Mais depuis,
le niveau de l'eau n'est pas
stable selon les riverains
inquiets pour la santé du lac.
- Je ne sais pas s'il va mourir
à la longue, mais ça avance,
ça avance et rétrécit, il y a
beaucoup d'algues aussi.
- Les résidents ont de quoi être
préoccupés, le vidage annuel
d'un lac n'est pas sans
conséquence, selon cette
experte.
- Ça va vraiment appauvrir
l'écosysteme aquatique
et empêcher les espèces qui sont
normalement présentes dans
un lac de s'installer
Les riverains que nous avons
rencontrés se sentent
impuissant.
BEATRIX BEISNER, dir. groupe de
recherche en environnement, UQAM
PIERRE M
- C'est sûr que quand on voit
ça, ça nous fait un petit
pincement au coeur, on se dit
est-ce que notre rêve est en
train de s'envoler?icipalité asn
côté que ces actions sont sans
conséquences.
Ici Jérôme Bergeron,
Radio-Canada, Val